ohne solche bilder kommt auch ein
optimistischer film nicht aus denn auch
wenn es niemand mehr hören will
wir stehen an einem wendepunkt
bevölkerungswachstum klimaerwärmung
ausbeutung von ressourcen
wenn wir jetzt nichts ändern wachsen
unsere kinder in einer welt auf in der
fossile rohstoffe nahrung und wasser
knapp werden davor warnt der renommierte
klimaforscher
starke worte
der emotionale ausgangspunkt für eine
aufrüttelnde dokumentation die
schauspielerin melanie laurent und der
aktivist die regierung wollten sich mit
diesem horrorszenario nicht abfinden und
haben sich mit ihrem team auf den weg
gemacht um konkrete lösungen zu finden
projekte die hoffnung machen das größte
problem unserer menschheit ist nicht die
klimaerwärmung nicht der welthunger ich
das ende der artenvielfalt nicht die
armut wenn ich die wirtschaftskrise
sondern die frage wie tun wir uns alle
zusammen um diese probleme zu lösen
gemeinsam ist das zauberwort dabei
können auch kleine projekte wirksam sein
zwei englische ladies begeistern ihre
stadt für ihre idee biologisches essen
an jeder ecke angebaut zugänglich für
alle ein anfang
ressourcen sparen in ganz großem stil
darauf stoßen die filmemacher in san
francisco in wenigen jahren haben dass
politik und bürger gemeinsam geschafft
denn müll radikal zu reduzieren
das ziel des films ist zu zeigen wie die
gesellschaft von morgen aussehen könnte
und so viele menschen wie möglich zu
motivieren sie mit aufzubauen
die idee des regisseurs geht auf
hunderttausend menschen haben den film
allein in der westschweiz schon gesehen
auch die schüler des lycée francais in
dübendorf lassen sich mitreißen
das ist auch etwas ist das mit uns zu
tun hat und unserem verhalten und das
ist menschen gibt die der initiative
nehmen und dass man daraus ändern so
positiv war und das war wirklich anders
von anderen dokumentarfilme über
umweltverschmutzung und so weiter wo sie
immer negativ sind und dann immer sagen
dass wir dass wir alles falsch machen
das macht lust mitzumachen doch hoffe
wir können nur alle zusammen etwas
verändern aber es muss wirklich von uns
kommen und zwar so schnell wie möglich
dass es keine zeit zu verlieren gilt hat
eine stadt am besten verstanden
kopenhagen hat eine milliarde euro in
windräder investiert um sich von erdöl
und kohle unabhängig zu machen und der
prominente stadtplaner young gel hat ein
modernes verkehrskonzept lanciert
bei claimcenter morris ist vorbei
schädling die für ein weit people to bei
den after 10 ihr fahrzeug bei siegling
der film zeigt verblüffende lösungen auf
vielen gebieten in der wirtschaft wenn
lokale währungen die menschen
unabhängiger machen wollen von den
globalen geldströme und die anbieter vor
ort fördern
in der bildung in schulen in finnland
die kinder bewusst zu
verantwortungsvollen menschen erziehen
oder in der landwirtschaft und
nachhaltige betriebe alternativen zu den
nahrungsmittelmultis bieten aber reichen
solche initiativen aus um das ruder
herumzureißen
viele finden uns naiv weil wir die macht
nicht besitzen sie denken dass es nicht
funktionieren kann weil die an der macht
nichts ändern wollen
das ist genau was der film vorschlägt
wie wir als wenn wir uns die macht
zurück holen und selbst entscheiden die
gesellschaft zu verändern
timo nowack etwas überladen sein mit
zahlen und fakten
doch die eindrücklichen projekte
beweisen der mensch ist nicht zur
trägheit verdammt der film motiviert mit
enthusiasmus zum do it yourself auch
wenn es nur im kleinen ist ich wäre
sicher bereit weniger fleisch zu essen
vielleicht nicht ganz zu verzichten aber
wenig
ich bin meinem film entschlossen
ingenieur zu werden um an dieser
bewegung teilzuhaben und meine lösungen
vorzuschlagen
ich wollte immer schon nach kopenhagen
und er hat gezeigt dass kopenhagen zb
probiert sich jetzt in fünf jahren denkt
ich vollkommen alleine energie versorgen
zu können
und ich denke das spricht sehr viel für
eine stadt und vertrieb wird bleibt zu
hoffen dass der film nachhaltig wert
dann wird dieser jugendliche den zug
nach kopenhagen nehmen und nicht das
flugzeug